in case the state is all wet or slippery
if any line unable to use the stairs
they please allow others to exit the
room before they go to the fire escape
door where there can be human assistance
assembly points will be in the public
car park at the side of the city sweet
please not today your evacuation to
collection belongings and please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by the council stuff
right apologies for absence i've got
three from punta me counselor dre that's
the Mason and counselor mrs. butcher are
there any other policies for absence
having any non members of the committee
agenda yes your most work thank you sir
djokovic right minutes of the meeting
held on the 40 of them at the 14th of
april two thousand and five which i
understand have been circulated are
there any issues with these minutes
please are you happy for me to sign them
yes
any declarations of interest I see my
best it's not calculation which I have
to stay and a reminder how something is
heka chairman that makes declares that
the together as if I was thinking of
something that happened at the last
meeting there was some concerns raised
that they meet another attended couple
days ago about dumb let me try and find
it not clarify with you isn't la moneda
yts chairman you wish for more
experienced person can do that is it the
chairman that asks for members to attend
a meeting of the executive always or can
any body propose that from the committee
it was interesting so enraged I believe
and they weren't there was a
clarification because I mean it was
concerns
this ridiculous was raised at the
planning at the training session I
perhaps for where the chairman of the
committee we all those were both human
screaming missing from calling an issue
for three members of the committee and
do it he's also it's not strictly the
Chen only no 33 on right okay 33 members
have a corner he come to the
Constitution it can be the chairman of
the committee or three other members
okay right it says Chairman's opening
remarks artist devil had a few
reflections since I was given this job
firstly I think what we are about it's
obviously representing the interests of
the electorate of Boxford district and
to do that I mean words of mr. Gradgrind
you shelter cages hard times winning
facts facts facts
and my experience the best way of
getting facts is to our short pitting
probing questions until we get
information that we looking for not a
great one for long winding questions
that are designed showed how much the
questioner knowns rather than how much
the people in front of them know and
also i'm getting my experience I think
except quite easy to avoid answering a
long winding question so a short could
short to the point but probing questions
think should be the orders that the day
which is about in all of the same and
see how we get on and by my two points
here will know that between your praise
or after the meeting and let me know how
that got in my first meeting and I feel
the poor to that right commercial use of
car parks charging policy I think
Michael is it you call this it before
treasure you know how this was coming in
early mind of a good luck would you be
helpful colleagues it might explain why
it was crawling and now I know it's like
this trouble the wrong winner 11
they're probably three reasons there is
probably not alone line the tribal
members will probably pick up on the
original reason was around the cost that
we are charging to the National filter
service the parking there was an issue
around the fact that to me but not every
other people found out but other people
certainly briefly as well that the base
is charging your 3.2 is unclear this is
the report from the director to the
portfolio holder where it says in the
last sentence NHS breast screening has
historically being offered on a reduced
cost basis but calculation fee based on
the pro rata price of an angle parking
firming 800 pounds to make that really
thoughtful the charge would be 800
pounds full use of it and therefore it
was going up to around 2,700 2,800 2,900
depending exactly how tall they were
going to be in there for it would appear
that that's not quite the case it would
appear that the 800-pound beeper biting
therefore it be 800 times five days
education for nine months with eternal
thousand pounds excluding vot and
obviously exclusivity I was then I'm
sure in 4.1 whether 11,000 pounds that's
mentioned in 2 to 3 80 or 90 degree 80
and I'm still not quite sure and check
months doesn't equate to be done 1,000
pounds that may be net and therefore I
felt the moms the cost places I thought
it was an excessive increase and then I
actually wasn't actually that excessive
increase it was just excessive to
Charleston NY here until exactly I
believe that the report is unclear and
I've a lot convince the people would
always some people obviously understand
it more night whereas I did not I think
the figures are edit around here
therefore the following special decision
based on correct understanding of old
and third you
I don't really think extractive be
charging an organization we should be
working with there's a lot of talk
around integrating services try to get
everyone to work together yet we're
charging a service which we're trying to
help integrate the genetics that was
broadly it on other people I think has a
long and head out pointer child also
certainly agree with but if I'm at the
problem i'll make was different was it
for me me personally it's a more
realistic issue and you know i just feel
that why should we be charging to
basically serve and look after our
residents and i feel that why do we
charge at all really i mean if you all
tried to work together we were trying to
relieve all these different sufferings
and illnesses and it should be a joint
effort and the figure to me seems a bit
sore firm here will there really I mean
I just feel personally it's a moral
issue and should we be charging them at
all and there I feel about it that
touches this but as most of the projects
as much as this one here that's how I've
come out with it good clean body assist
the committee with a increase yes or
from A to B and help start vs. I think
the increase from last year to this year
including the 80 is for Pam 16 for pound
16
two inches off the wall
what think the turtle total income of
increasing 4016 or knows oddly chart
that we charge the NHS the difference
between last year and this year will be
an increase of port for pound 16 in
total in tons per year to year 13
between this year and last year the
agrees before power 16 display rocker
figures that we've been charged him
anything at all last year we've been we
haven't charged them since july two
thousand thirteen don't know in this
come from I know where I understood
aware that we in case I was only
depression with that kind of traffic on
London New York under the system as
explained in the report and clearly as a
new suggested arrangement outlined in
the end table attached to the report and
the difference in charge would be
full-time 16 did it was charged there's
bigger charge this yeah um the report as
the heading commercial use of car parks
in what way is an interspace reading the
commercially is
that's good enough person look what you
do you wanna well sort of charity
chairman it's not charity even and I
think that's the distinction
that is everything's not charge a
commercial use in life
so humans ever think it's not actuality
but is everything else in the universe
into the theme going black and white
view things rather commercial or charity
everything's not modalities commercial I
don't regard west wing of the units s
that's a commercial activity neither is
a charity either what's going to tariffs
that set up do you do is to put those
hold of you God and then just Wesley as
a good instructor
now I don't conclude commercial activity
but I need to convert accept it as a
charity thank you did you have a
question this is one government
department charging another it's just
money going around in a circle it's
utterly pointless yes I think you also
got to remember that we've also got to
make sure that for our residents that we
are gaining as much money we came to
cover the cost of the car parts that is
one of our only sources of income there
are other things on our budget that are
going to increase for example the refuge
collection it going to be really
increases on that so we have got to keep
an eye on now income yes I appreciate is
coming from one government profile until
another if you call the NHS a government
department mine can I can can you
clarify as far as I understand we have a
breast screening unit somewhere within
the district virtually every day of the
year is that correct Nautilus correct
now I under to wear that it's here
nearly every day of the unit well there
is it does cover there a substantial
chunks of time when it is writing about
the district I believe that okay I think
it's the same unit that as goes to
customary I believe but I want also what
is the actual total revenue income that
we have for this unit across the
district for a year last year it was
2133 pounds and thirty four pence
including me later so we've gone up to
so the details of why she and forty
pounds a fatal then decrease this year
is 2137 pound fifty to that figure not
the increase of two thousand
so the vets that's their loss
effectively if we didn't charge but then
of course we've got to take off that a
certain amount of additional revenue
that is generated by ladies and families
I've ever coming to use the youth of the
facility that's one of the questions
that I sort of anticipated and officers
very kindly gave me some assets this
afternoon yes there is a slight increase
of the use of the car parks as near as
they can work out on those days of
around the two percent increase but as
it states here however the figures
should be viewed with some course and
there's there may other factors
contributing increase whether school
holidays particular event in the area
roadworks say so it's not dip we can't
definitely say that there is an increase
when the rescue list is there there are
a lot of other factors are creepy so at
the moment if if for example the council
decided that we wouldn't charge we're
looking at a loss of just over 2,000
pounds 2000 not even 2,200 pounds not
best correction the paper was as an
afterthought I thought at the end
mentioned reputational risk how do you
see that one what where does and I know
it's crept into Santa local media the
deuce is a serious whisper council now I
personally done
is is there is there any areas within an
hour I mean I understand that we can
accommodate the usual hidden self there
rose hopefully without losing any
parking spaces it doesn't doesn't
specifically lose parking spaces but it
restricts access to some of the parking
spaces so no logos and still we used
they can be used but we difficulty if if
the car park is full so apart from are
there any other areas and within and
some of the power on the car parks that
could be used I know we're talking about
our revenue loss but that would not
impinge on the parking facilities I
certainly in the fright house I don't
believe that is the case and the Hopley
car park in the South a road is the one
you're always mentioned and I'm not sure
exactly where it partners in the third
well it personal bubble behind the
middle I'm not sure exactly where it
parks within the car park but I don't
think it if there is any particulars
ways you could park before you foot
truck without making some sort of
further restriction I'll float another
idea there in if for example in
Webster's way where we have a number of
recycling units and I don't know
whatever you income from those it is if
they wait that would free up a position
that would accommodate that you knew i
would suggest and yes but as you rightly
say you've got the lots of income from
the recycling the credits the recycling
unit the year but that
we like that sometime have you to
substantially over the last few years
hasn't it some of those incomes I
couldn't answer that question I don't
know not what bullfighting degeneration
well you know clean the screen name sits
records back to the car park so I
believe it does and you do lose about
five car parking spaces and access to
some of as you say are very difficult
especially if it's a car pop in there
may be ugly is not necessarily getting a
nap but it's definitely part at the very
end or the car park just one particular
point one of the questions I ask that
sort of anticipated from you guide as
the NHS ever raised any objection to
pain for the car park the outside
receipt is no never and it's been some
20-odd years since this was introduced
and I think we understand that I have
that within their their party too
to supply is facility across the the
district is a part of their charge and
they expect to pay this this video that
easily any other about that that's the
official programs in the dread in the
echo I believe effectively that some
charge I'm countless charities i'm done
but they they expect to vote on that now
that's kind of what i would like to see
us to me as a council was the only games
to charging I don't think is right and I
would love to see us as a council of
championing that ethos amongst other
councils across the country in the NHS
must spend an awful lot of money if they
do this with every council he must cost
him a fortune and I don't see why we
can't be a council that leads the way in
helping NHS reduce some of they are
going to it's quite frankly if you know
just post.really new put on wanted to
come to railing and didn't want to pay
the charges anymore there are
alternative venues it's big nothing
Malcolm I agree I've seen it before in
the travelers joy pub which is private
karjala it's been there before don't say
that a little seamlessly I'm not aware
that that's been the case certainly I
like that like you're you Jamie it was
living a slightly sis or any different i
may be focusing on VHS wonder yeah in
principle there are other ones you know
there's two station car pox which other
neither of which over full to capacity
they could go there so the business
could be saying any of us where we could
we not be a council that looks at this
you know the revenue we get from it
isn't particularly nod it could have
quite an effect and negative effects on
that the reputation and people's views
upon us although could we not use that
can we not be accountable assess persons
in life i tried central board your point
but of course also as well we've got to
take on to it into account although it's
only a small amount of revenue that
would be a loss of revenue to our
rainbows yep and i completely accept
that i think in my opinion
if people were given the choice they
would probably rather see increases
elsewhere and felicita reduce all this
crap in on stamping people's more
realistic view of that a certain this is
feeding the press I've received no
communication whatsoever either one
worthy I hope I mean there are some
because we have been given some some of
you because I've ever seen nothing but
that's fine I've just I think for me
personally I'd like see scrap that I
think the amounts we're talking about a
significant enough and I would like to
see us encouraging other councils to do
the same and actually be no more get
good line turn turn situation around and
actually give I take your game now take
a border for encouraging other councils
to do lock boy okay thank you miss you
and I so I've already expressed my view
about the moralist in your head but I
also balance there with a view that we
have to be extremely careful generally
because if we stop giving to one
particular group then we'll have a
burger is covered a long run in the same
treatment so we have to be very mindful
to this because it's not we're not
talking we might be talking about this
in principle but we are talking about
bigger picture and on so on he's running
through my mind and I I do understand
that right but so one of the things I
was just sitting there thinking is as an
authority as a district council can we
could we so reverse the situation I find
in an area this agreeable to us and see
if the national health or the national
service and trust whatever he is want to
read that her Adam then
that ain't it to their different groups
we want to use that particular area so
we can negotiate a reasonable figure so
if we let you control it instead of
losing X amount of week here in X amount
of you there the answered as we actually
find somewhere it's suitable for
everybody at a nominal rail ring and let
the National Trust allocate accordingly
I take on board towards your idea I'm
not sure that we would have anywhere
within the district would be suitable
for that because you need for example
where the car park where their position
take fright house example it's easy
access easy parking it's next to the
railway station on a bus routes etc etc
so you need to take all those things
into a quelle okaying to running hot
keys and operatives a railway station
and it's perhaps are people running
raley's not near to the railway station
but there in the center now to find
another site but you have to put a
40-foot truck is going to be a bit of a
tall order I feel but I'll take on body
point if there is anywhere i'll
certainly no just also thinking has
parishes of good ideas some of the
arrests they can build towards the most
a district issued parishes as well so
now that other than sort of parks you
know that there's a car parking or until
hockley and parish council with but you
only have 40 foot truck in there yeah
Chris it's just I'm not to come back in
what each other's it's a question but my
family haven't used this particular
service not not in not this one is it a
Walkingstick
good point this point the type of the
leaf by my wife is getting cut up early
when budgeting if we concentrate at the
moment on the press square union but I
mean we would even highlighted that
there are other national health units in
operation within the district on
occasions what would have you be if it
became a you know if it wasn't just
press screaming it was well being in
this prostrate cancer it was whatever
new system came up blood here whatever
news new Union came into being that
we're not aware or fear that I think
that they're on their way we would have
assuming the we will have the same
criteria for those as well yes and I'd
look at each individual case and on its
own merits obviously but yes I think
when the basis would be pretty Billy the
Sun and just just one thought from what
we're talking about all terms place is
the one in rockford for example there is
a big car park still at the rocks for
the hospital or the site of the right
hospital but they prefer not to use it
may not run ok confused if used so
capable so nine let's start off with the
reporter received today by mr. Stratton
because I asked for the breakdown of
charges over the last three years the
only charge on Latino traces on the
fifteenth of july two thousand thirteen
there's no charge for last year of like
confirmation at a later date no please
preferably other ones have been charged
with so variously from this list I'd
have to come back on yes I'm say that I
don't imagine I don't know the answer to
that question if it's not been accounted
for in terms of we've invoice the NHS
then they need to look at what am I just
wonderful business work wreck was very
quietly it comes very close to the 2133
you mention Russell and what goes so I
tell you i buy that but happy to come
back on that particular medicine I'll
awesome character pressure than charging
them for charging is set out in our fees
and charges which pretty clear 20 pounds
for the first place seven power 53 smoke
going off an incident on 51st space for
every day after there for ten months i
make they'd ever 1607 pounds eight page
which is very close to the 11,000 pounds
mentioned in the report is that
therefore how that figure has been
arrived at the actual word easy is only
just over 11,000 pounds ten months using
that's five base because I'm costs over
it if it hasn't found those that that is
that elusive for exclusivity or the ship
is exclusive okay we're talking about
this before meeting actually in
some of the Michigan is increasing that
we have to clarify everything closure is
very interested in his own the [ __ ]
protocol devastating it wouldn't be an
increase in traffic you are you with
that's actually a and this is where
investment always very misleading
potentially if it is inclusive that
means the actual parking charges for ten
months would be and bear with me one
moment 2432 pounds 73 pins oh no that
would be the charge ever compared to can
I just are so helpful having the life of
that Featherman I have arrived at 20
pounds of the first parking space yes
seven pounds fifty yes for that day
another four spaces then and after that
seven power 50s her space every day as I
five spaces every day and I've done that
over a year then bun 1012 tentative
isn't it I wasn't working on a daily
basis yet it and that comes that set the
tractor beauty charges for ten thousand
and twelve pounds fifty points 10 12 to
11 six and seven point oh eight if we
then do the 800 pounds times five is
4,000 pounds including back divided are
they getting air up over 10 months
that would be 3333 pounds then if you
remove the VA T it comes to 2700 7,000
chair pills which means actually let's
be honest as proposed if that is correct
you actually proposed a lowering of the
charges so this is growing this is what
I'm ready to the report I think I'm very
unsure what it means in it and I don't
have corporate nonetheless is going
increase charges which to be fair pro
thoughts as well get enough of a tomato
may have seen charges I don't really
don't know what's going on now but the
figure that I have is that the current
feed just 2133 found 34 pets including
VT the price that is going up to the
year including the a-team is 2137 plan
50 which is an increase of four pound 16
included a wouldn't have been helpful to
try using same criteria as has been used
on Republic you're providing us just get
that I asked the question of the officer
as to what the actual fee that the NHS
won't be paid and that is over again on
the period is that for a year to a year
that doesn't agree to the record that
figure does not prefer green to recall
and told Justin right there were three
points the first one little bit so it
was as I say to the pro rata basis i say
to hear that on a pro rata
three points first one is what was the
reasons I'm Rochford house for not a bit
not using me facility said I better I'm
not reason to know why they have of the
house in question but they don't use it
claims the plate house so as I would ask
the question why do they use the freight
house and knocked butch and i think it's
probably because it's a different part
of the net the NHS and I think we've had
this discussion before in there they
feel that it's important that their
facilities is kept secure so i don't i
don't believe that they that they their
preferences for the for their facility
to be open in to these sorts of other
uses how are we different part of the
National Health Service yes we've been
as I've been confirmed in writing from
the hospital I'm not asking the
questions now put different trusts to
moonfest if you ever are the National
sodium fine the other point I was gonna
is I know that there's a restriction in
the pub car park epic flying is there's
a visit simply outside the GP area for
the would you could could actually be
used i think is problem with that is
that although there's the GP area there
and it would restrict access to that yes
there's also a couple of businesses that
back onto that that have access there's
also a home just around the side of the
back there which again has access I
think you'd have problems rocking up a
number of accesses to other properties
it directly outside the Jeep Eddie
Pepitone I can't see how it could
blodgett church oh no I think it's worth
we're saying it's my understanding that
the screen unit you know has looked at
the locations where it might be
appropriate for them to to put the the
unit and those locations have become
established over over a period of time
and I think is their preference of
choice for the particular vacations
industry that have been used and we'll
go over appears i don't think we should
lose sight of that fact you know need to
have a dialogue with the the NHS about
the location and they might say well
hold on a second it's fine that you to
suggest another location but actually
you know the way things have been
working and years and the fact that
people know that we're here or that in
this particular vacation isn't working
arrangements point taken mar 30 part of
our point is following on from michael
sorry i cancel if I
I would want the report amended to so it
clarifies the
it funded all the amounts which shall be
presented so it's not it's clear because
that I personally found it but when I
was trying to calculate I found it quite
taken back tape out how how you come to
those those figures i think if we
clarify the figures which are in the
document so everyone's aware of where
the costs I had the customer arrived I
think though that will help our just
saying an alternative sites command key
there might be the community center
don't think they'd like me saying that
probably not the residents neither but
it is a large car park which is locked
up which can be sensitive topic
committees in pick up large cubes car
bomb but my my road or would be to some
questions that you need to ask is
firstly do they want and I'm secondly
our suspect they probably want a fee for
doing here as well as the community
center no it's just an alternate I'm a
bit obviously there are questions to be
asked if it was even considered but it
did but there is a large car party which
is locked every night and which could be
used if it's you say for hopeless
example you for put it down onto the
augusta state down into the railway
station but is that the right place
would they want to be there you know
what
around the industrial state I agree with
even tell jamie lee Jang and just a
quick question why is the approach car
fog excluded full charges you among the
approach car parked in rain well I'm
shuman has the ones in this report says
Horan hop up and into Saturday it has
the Faceman it says in brackets
excluding approach cut off because
that's the one car parking made you look
at the rear end has an awful lot of
space from is never full and could quite
easily accommodate those 40 boots unit
but it seems to be excluding so that's
added you can ride that car park free or
do alternative charges apply to that car
park terms of charges apply to the
market I'm creative sound yeah but I not
mentioned in this report what those
charges are because that is one part of
it is never fault it has run average
2013 spices and our unit on internet
let's come here to cover the in screech
car part but both of the both brain car
parts inside which I'll see you bak
eaten neither are in for whether the end
I'm just not interested why we've got
child is here that one of those car
parks is excluded yet there's no mention
of what the charges are or if you can I
thou that to me gives the impression you
can hire any space in a particular car
parking railing which is run by the
council which has ample room for a
breast feeding unit I just
I'm just following on from what Sean
said I think these locations are
established and also they're visible as
well I think probably they want to
encourage people to use the units in the
future so if it was in a more remote
location there's possibility people in
CA then I grew in Sean completely I
think you know that these in HS the NHS
or the units they do need something for
into that I personally don't think a
main station car park is particularly
the moment a lot of people will get
there by train and everyone will be able
to find the station so a station car
park is quite an obvious place but it
doesn't actually answer we're agreed to
report that a particular car park is
excluded from this yet there's no
information on there what charges do
apply to epson can come back if they're
already Kevin then guess there are
charges there's a different charging
regime that applies to the tipton
approach car park exactly why it's
excluding from the from the chart and
schedule another to clarify that at that
point please yeah thank you Jim
I think this important needs to go back
to portfolio over the form of the
situation and I'll give you three of all
the reasons why first of all I don't
think the point is clear it's a lot of
discussion over what it means it's not
there financially I think in these
classification secondly report is about
commercial charging and i think
everybody's happy with the commercial
charging expect of our counselor here
basically find out the approach but the
commercial master is ok exceeds the
charity aspect at its v NHS aspect which
i think should we delve in a separate
report I mean passing assistant when you
put further holder has got you can waive
charges for charity so exciting the PDS
I wanted to have a screening NEPA pets
you can in fear they give one hundred
percent reduction 08 some college was a
bundle into charity if you give my
husband doesn't give you serviced but
you can't about the unit test so I think
there should be separate report for
being HSM charges and the third reason
is that the review committee i think is
clearly a necessity for charging at all
and fourthly if we look at our
illustrious group of plan i don't think
it's in relation it ties up with some of
our values in their committed to the
community and delivering immunity I
think did it ring in unity that's
anything about to living in unison again
top a thousand a year I'm sorry I think
if you try to match to try to take the
mole in points and attach it to
council policy I think our girl could
start a good plan committee to the
community and delivered immunity and
creating a better future together and I
think about these we can justify waving
which are completely closed by most of
my people is another question little
superb sir psycho FEMA what I want to
say is you can't just stick one of these
anywhere people think it's not just
young people who uses facilities it's
older people and our lady of over 80
who's discovered fan she had breast
cancer I would say she would want walk
very far shouldn't be able to walk back
home you've got to have it somewhere
where everyone can actually get to take
your point you know if if example we
offer them the approach car parked in
row d yeah it's not far from a bus
service but for somebody like that it
would mean walking the physical distance
I don't think the the breast unit would
be particularly keen on using that
particularly we'd have to ask them I
don't know that for a fact but so they
may be if we could do yes but you've
also got to take into account the
scenario that love just given yep we
drag our side you know they will take
that into account well I'll take one
more question King Jack the means for
your sorting through thank you
in the last words this is an able to
share it's not so much a question it's a
point of view of her life but like that
was advocating all of this if i may and
this is a non city of this team very
interested on support because of lack in
suggesting what he did and i support
everybody else of others do and i've set
my viewers but at the end of the day is
their choice oh they come to us and
where they park and we can put all of
our billions and really we should really
define this down to cost you know I
support with you but I really think it's
about they come to you they should be
experienced and they should be go shake
with you where they want to place these
things we should I don't think the
council should stop dictating to the
health service we are going to start
planting these services it's just I just
wanted to sort of play devil's advocate
that one and then we plot all these
situations but they should have a better
knowledge than us by knowing the
clientele that's all I really wanted to
put in there if they came to us and said
what we would prefer to use X car now
well that yes we would certainly
consider it we'd look at it and take on
board there they're very stay close but
it would be their choice okay thanks
everybody for their contributions and
questions well I think you get the fees
and further clarification wiping need
you can last pull get in touch with you
about dating and you folks if that's
what the little switch and it can come
you have to come to a resolution whether
you can refer it back or leg up to avoid
you yeah yeah yeah yeah you so you have
to make them you have two choices one
but you can bet the decision stand or
two you can recommend that Mike
reconsiders the decision stating the
reasons why that that's your two choices
anybody got any views obviously optical
thing I I would propose that this a we
could do with some a better
clarification of the report as both Mike
and others of highlighted thing
ultimately I think we all are you to
reconsider the whole scenario of whether
we as Jeremy Bulloch should be looking
to be proactive in assisting we
appreciate this going to cost us 2,200
pounds but perhaps the effective could
reconsider all or review the situation
that we will be proactive that we would
actually be going out and giving a
service to i'm guessing over 40
protecting the over 40,000 ladies within
the district and that that may lead the
way ahead and then if it's going to cost
us 2,400 pound and possibly less than
that because we're gonna have the
additional income very that that may be
the way we would like you to proceed I
don't know if other people agree with
that proposal of something
need to sentence I think there is a
slight caveat in terms of if that is
what we agreed to do weathergirl the
services at the NHS have any expect to
going to use on our land without been
paying a fee because they'll also be
exempt that's only containing we say yes
will do this one that open the
floodgates as it were to public health
but I don't want to hold your other
services only one thing you can
configure I mean I am sailing to let to
say that he needs to be on a
case-by-case basis Jeremy classic
question sorry did just just a
clarification for that and I think the
last the last point is is it is a good
one earth but i think that portfolio is
going to going to consider the review
committees views on the NHS best
screening unit i think you know i think
that there may very well need to be some
games in relation to the review
committees view on all of the other
related facilities that might very well
then say hold on a second if it's now
free of charge in the car park we'd like
to go there as well is there a limit to
that is it just national health service
is it all the other well-being sorts of
facilities or how to you know clearly we
can give consideration to that but in
terms of in terms of whether the view
committee has a view be useful to hear
that playing out i would like to be seen
all and
I think if you have a we've talked a lot
about pro screening interest or C is
extremely important if you were
statistic in cancer screening unit we
will soon have an issue if we were
charging the testicular cancer screening
but not possibly if I just think NHS
should be exempt personal thanks baby
charitable work the discretion maybe one
more point of increasing yeah I mean
support arm it's not my practical
question I my instincts and death others
are if it's an extra screening for a
life-threatening condition then I'd say
yes and then we're defining
life-threatening world not using it can
I take a take the piper I'm busy this is
my purse is my instinct honest oh and
also I would say have up to one we've
got through the games really hot can
watch but I don't mind if there was one
streaming unit in lately at one time
thing Warren hockey or something else I
more than watching for a third I think
we could have thought that and I think
that's some thinking you got something
that's happenin it why can't give you a
living active that I have come concerns
about 7 comments of crisps mates with
regards to it has to be a
life-threatening illness are you
suggesting the portfolio holder would
have to make a decision as to whether
it's a life-threatening illness or not
I'm not sure I want to do that secondly
with regards to NHS now we've already
determined that NHS is not a charity as
its sits in the middle of the two of
nitrogen what about police what about
fire brigade what about the lifeboat
institute not then they are terrible but
you know the police and the fire brigade
all the additives what about their where
do you draw the line on that on that
basis we could end up with the tar part
of those faces in those car parks being
used every day every week in you think
we gotta put some limitation into the
sanaya go up in the last word I think
it's big quietly clearly said nothing
our group with them council fact that if
you have five space in each car pop
which are available throughout the year
Betty any restrictions goes five and you
restricted to to help own after under
standard scenario of the fire service
possibly and also the police pointing it
might be possible they they could have
space but this was called in regarding
the health screening as I see it
mother's breast screen press pasolini
bit on the screen in general and that's
how I would you see I think any health
screening
he's helpful to prevent any
life-threatening disease Dean and that's
how I said I think we've given that a
very good airing colleagues the eye and
thanks to Mike and Sean and if you could
provide us with some further information
in a clarified for my think the
committee room anyway in it to send
backers you can
the life Spanish Inquisition write some
stuff away item seven the housing
allocation and what couple of questions
myself doesn't to start and it says in
the paper work that our previous screen
was successful then we decided to sort
of rationalize it along the practice of
other authorities well what benefits to
the council were there in moving away
from that was your God is successful
what do we see is being a lucky benefit
looks like it just as I didn't I didn't
I didn't leap okay I think the key I
think the key point is that it's
appropriate regardless of whether a
schema successful not to review on a
regular basis nothing that's what the
purpose of this report is have a look at
at whether or not there was a
justification for adjustments in the in
the allocation scheme and
notwithstanding the comment about
success or otherwise I think you was
reached that there was some
justification
in effing reaching a conclusion that
there be an adjustment to the scheme so
that's what was brought forward through
the attitude through the report the
reason I ask is the fourth also folks
the question of possibly increased costs
because more people you having to
someone can have to make great use of
bed and breakfast or private
accommodation it uses disease is in
place so I was trying my head doesn't
cost benefit and that says particularly
at a time when councils were aware that
money is tight and we're going down a
policy with an additional costs I was
just wondering how times you want the
benefits work so upset that i walloped
up I mean I think I think the point is
that the current arrangement intense of
residency qualification is it is a
little bit complicated and the proposal
was I think to simplify that it's not
unduly different but it's it's it's a
simpler arrangement and as it also says
in the report is seeking to you know
take that issue into a kind of potential
but additional costs and reach a balance
about whether the adjustment is is
acceptable or not I think there's no
doubt that the evidence seems to suggest
that some of the particularly some of
the periods that have been adopted by
certain councils have had unseen
consequences Gosnell's being mentioned
and they have a I think seven years
qualification and that has had locations
for for homelessness B&B so it's a
careful balance that we thought need to
be struck and the proposal is that it is
I think just simplifying the final
question we've wanted for me these are
many back of a cigarette packet cup and
preciate they're not sort of very easy
to be fine but is there any feeling as
to what they increased costs might be
these questions are to know you know now
I can go and take our ID number unknown
coughs and
slightly used ebenefits nothing that's
much anybody else and ask questions if
it's ugly had these figures submitted to
us could you just sort of explain them
to me Joe bd17 coming today I mean I'm I
get [ __ ] bad day with a new movie new
impact Bambi are getting Egypt over
potentially difference yeah actually a
difference of whatever that total is
I've worked out yeah yeah thats panties
a fair chance of sneaking housing it's
and a priority so so effectively you by
increasing in two to three event we
don't anticipate the most vulnerable
group they wouldn't be endearing impact
on a tour
and then the next one of always middle
for units yeah tell people on the lick
on the list yet further questions for
mr. that's a bit much movement in the
last say phone i would like to see exact
figures but not not much as far as i
know i can never get exactly cuz change
better no not right now i think i can
get exact figures in love one god just
got there's a kind of questions in a
[ __ ] hostage my label they probably
applies the Chairman's view wife white
if asking is successful doing have to
adopt a criteria of other authorities it
would six be there will be a lot chairs
what is ways their waste material for
being successful and I can see doc nice
10-foot reviewed and if we then say
successful while we changing it I
wouldn't know what that criteria reason
why we felt that we were not
successfully done where it wasn't
successfully done what was the failure
failing in that scheme Z boss determine
I think an answer that question a few
months ago sadly settings worth
reviewing but I don't think well as a
result of that review I think I think
you know the conclusion was that there
was some justification in in some fine
the arrangement so that's what's been
people especially so in what way is this
simple number well it does it make it
simpler then if thats it's a simple one
on criteria rather than a sort of been
the band-aid approach to to the
assistant and Chris yeah I'll looking
particularly for rationale behind
removing the alternative codification
having the de MIDI stick for four years
in the past five what's the rationale
behind remember that under the
simplification problem don't think that
I think that was the episode up anything
I can see tsunami of somebody's living
here with your parents when their
husband their out of work they get them
off of the job somewhere it's a bit if
he might not work out they try it for a
month or two and which others follow
through a bit by and quite again
wouldn't move about how to the parents
whatever still with a place of their own
but it doesn't be the rightful couple of
months they suddenly lose their place
I'm I can see a case for tightening up
on that wall of it was four and a half
using the waterslide yes but honestly by
this response I wonder do it it
discourages people from taking mr. Ivy
enjoy Hudson which I'm including
yourself
my point was the same very similar
actions as a particular people group is
that aiming at a specific time the flu
it's got a strange but application areas
interesting for three years and to lose
that would that affect one will take the
grave or not and I was my question is
wrong thank you sir those are
collapsible questions as I think now
that guy because it's a similar thing
for asking I've got a problem with that
having paid employment sick of not less
than 16 hours i think most people if you
look around will find that lots of
contracts do stop started less than 16
hours nowadays and if you're sewing
younger you have to own earn the right
to have more hours guaranteed sorry to
say i am aware of people who have start
work on twelve-hour guaranteed contracts
so they wear for was not putting fine
i'm always here on as the i-140 house
even yes yeah and that's 1 i've become
where they may well be working more than
that hours but they were going to prove
they don't necessarily in it
which is a calming I would did not fire
on the figures we props from jodi about
the leon where the axe Falls we were to
be honest this comes across as a way to
to me to cut our waiting this isn't
covered by that many perhaps base early
pups them in one area which is a one
bedroom accommodation which is most
people know is quite rare in the
district not appear to be it might seem
as though we're trying to cut now the
problem people don't want my bedroom
although in Bad Seed most out of the one
bit property is fancy which is it's not
I thought maybe you still on the waiting
list annual could well probably next few
years get a property if their work was a
one bedroom property around and is cut
by 19 of the 21 in total two bedroom
properties aight about the team a
cutting level and then of the 304
bedroom and the sheltered and old
suggest shelter models with vulnerable
people they're all cut in bed see i
would suggest a load bad day you might
result is more vulnerable that's
certainly one posting has you mean i
think perhaps you might find of fantasy
penfold people when some fun fitness as
well they're not they haven't got a
family there on the ice then one
businessman accommodated whatever
problem with that and and the other
problem is we are moving further and
further away
from right ear of the housing
associations if you go to rockford
housing association you'll find ur their
criteria for proteases anyone anywhere
can have a property on there if they're
on there is that property anywhere they
want so they can get a Rockford property
so while we're restricting people within
the residence inn perhaps you what
should you might have three out of five
years what's it housing the group's I
won't even from Scotland tomorrow into
the property on the basis of their 25
second fitting of the of the Housing
Association properties origin then
I appreciate as short as highlighted
that the need for periodic review if we
have had the Douglas review and in line
basically but in line with a number of
adjacent districts would there have been
some bigger impact on us i mean we then
become through so the soft tap for
potential homeless people using the
opportunity to move into Roger because
we've got a softer criteria than them
somewhere else is all part of it and
then but we should take this into
account or or or is it you know no
impact at all we I'm concerned that we
reviewed this we've come up with an idea
but if we don't do this then we will
suddenly be swamped by people drifting
in from south end or as a little wet
ever trying to get on the list and take
out or in page on the big club white
your deliciously friends number of years
to get their place on a list I think
it's some inevitability that the people
were you know in our own south essex so
again put it that way we'll look at the
qualifying criteria and make decisions
bit based on what they what they see and
there's probably some evidence of that
so to a degree the review is highlighted
a potential for actually safeguarding
the residents have been in this area and
waiting on the list for a period of time
that we're just making ourselves no more
of a honeypot than any other early
there's no advantage to come here we've
already got out our set list we already
know what who's on it and nobody's going
to come in and jump over the top of them
so to speak when it's day miss Chapman
one of the keys is is to try and ensure
that people who are local people and
sort of committee to you know to rupture
and have the opportunity to to talk to
to get accommodation in the district
where the questions are going so I just
come back on the simplification point I
haven't been convinced that this thing
is simpler I think in which some
respects it may be more complex
certainly in the light detective working
where you have you decided where we're
always paid employment confirmed or a
conformation of paid employment in the
area that's in very simple tween now
it's going to be having paid employment
of not less than 16 hours a week for at
least the past 12 months step as I mean
average 12 hours is have we have that
demonstrated it seems more context to me
that one so I'm really not convinced of
the certification of it thank you
put in place you need to see how they
have the same as before it is the same
coding it's whether to accept the
decision or whether you feel we want to
make very active portfolio holder in the
reasons why so could i ask if we could
ask the new portfolio horrible they feel
about the policy where's that
appropriate for example dr. human foot
achieving this would be referred back to
that's lelani believe there's the new
year I'll be a lot to read I think I
already said it beginning I because this
wasn't signed of you I mean I know very
little about the detail of what is
behind this and it's really strange it
from most of your questions and
statements there's a lot of complexity
within this in a little detail so I
think if I had have been able to get my
head around all of this and the reasons
why by now I would have been something
of a miracle yes if you decide that way
we'll come back to me and maybe then I
will have a better on and this evening
you're hoping that something that's
being signed off by someone else the
office is her answer to your questions
because I do not understand the detail
at this point in time would is an answer
Michael that's not what someone like to
shrew I'm acceptance or move further
back well I bahama refer back I think
they would benefit us as a really said
I'm fine I'm possibly the new book pilot
hopeful as well I don't mean enemy
that's not good I take this away yeah
but she just picked up it wasn't
believable passing to second exactly
okay I have a little problem with out
nopee open all photos have olds happy
you too and have anybody to sit in from
that okay obviously the new majority
view the community grew further back and
the recent art I'm having for me IPO
between leads but just clarification
with regards to some of the changes only
proposed wordings for the actual issues
in particularly regards to local
connection residents and local
connection working with a view to me the
working hours and possibly for me the
zero-hours contract issue I think of
just possibly lot to see that I
mentioned I just asking am i seein good
micra said something about you could be
how does that work with zero hours and
how do people prove you're surely be
proof is in the pay slips you have to be
making more complex surely if you have a
job for 12 if you have a supreme off
close together the previous criteria was
a job where's the 16 hours a week
how do you mind to secure those around
four okay can I close that down and bite
into goo you should be able to prove it
to de facto gloves and a UI having to
rely on the contract because he would do
that as contact some people working on
12 hours I did I don't know what you
want that yeah I mean I think one of the
points about this particular issue is
that you know people have up here main
approaches and said yeah we've got
confirmed appointment and they got a
piece of paper that says confirm the
appointment you know and the reality is
it's anything but confirmed in quiet
anything so that the fundamental
difference between you know that process
and as has just been said you know the
ability to put forward in a pay slips
that provides detailed evidence so far
off both actual let me bang ah so that's
the life period it's easier to look back
retrospectively than punters whether the
dolphin the tubular okay different
reasons whether or not it was simple
monetizing fees for that goes into the
pot legal as the better person I'm sorry
kannada santoshi chairman that circle in
I think that portfolio and it doesn t
does need a bit more clarification as to
exactly what you would like look Ted cuz
I'm come Sam if I left here now we are
we really clear others yeah i mean
really i think it's just with regards to
whether or not the change from me
resident here for two years to three
years is making simply yes if I as well
as the hours that may be the criteria
we've been told by the office areas look
this it was a successful scheme we've
made it simpler it's been a simpler
because of those two changes in
particular so all those same changes
making it simple
so just letting a straight face again I
just think the but more there are people
people zero-hours contracts with
possibly are going to be ones that are
slightly more was because of the nature
of the artist I'd say if somebody was on
zero-hours contract and they couldn't
prove that they had worked 16 hours a
week every week which is what happens on
those areas confirm that they wouldn't
be completely disregarded maybe there
could be an average calculation you want
zero hours contracts as to how many
hours per month for mystery girls was
often you have a 12-hour contract and
but if you work for next sighs I don't
have an issue with you would be close
but you'll be working 20 hours of some
young as you know 12 others so it is
unclear whether ease you have to work
with at least six feels like we
basically they happily new year as does
it make it sound okay so while you go to
them when we come back next time ask a
lot more questions that you haven't
given business for now we're pointing
clarification I don't think that's how
it works the median chair you can unplug
it in one one time you can't call you in
a second time though I think Michael
will confirm that in the past could help
in the next time the decision is my need
is not subject calling but because of
that the lighters are clarifying also
that if we don't go down this road but
potentially we could be
more vulnerable for other people moving
taking potentially into the district and
creating a bigger problem we currently
have times so that is the reason kind of
you told us the reason I'm guessing
because we're told is a simplification
yep people so do you need you know to go
on thinking hmm it does cousin very
thing I'd read looking under misc
implication that should have been
something there implying that we are
vulnerable if you don't change the
policy that should have been there set
the germany kicked off this item i'm
talking about the financial implications
for homelessness are you satisfied now
about that issue i'm satisfied to the
extent that it's going to be a finger in
the air whatever anybody does i mean you
could in theory ice and pubs calculate
the 42 difference between the two sets
and say what would that cost us and for
what would that have cost is over the
past three year period but obviously
looking into the future is simple none
of us possess possess a crystal ball but
i mean there must be some thought at
some stage given to what the cost might
be given the tip viewing a lot of catch
bugs as i can see
so any help you could give us will be
quite flimsy you're welcome to stay with
oh yes this is right item hate the
overhaul work over I've been informed
that there should have been a couple of
additions to this list one we have a
free treasury management of using year
and the second we have to have two
reviews a year of Community Safety
Partnership so that i get from one piece
with regulation no investment go to have
exactly two thousand and finally
commenters is that obviously as moving
got the new bodies and prop project
groups and i think it will be very
helpful if everybody was available to be
on one of other things it is shopping
this here i'm told in a way that I can't
quite envisage that we've got to
prioritize this prioritizing things by
committees like starting with a horse
then Avila crown in my experience
because everybody may have their pet
number one and so I'm looking to my more
experienced colleagues to guide me on
this or not you're having to do it in
kind chopping
Nestle try and help hopefully Community
Safety Partnership is there done by the
committee and we only have one last year
but our training session afterwards it
was agreed by members that it would have
been better to have had to so basically
they come to committee twice a year and
i would suggest possibly September and
februari might be leave the top times
but I was told to give us a starting
being so that's I'll just program the me
to the agenda
with regard to rip up because of the
changes of the reorganization the policy
has to be amended with regard to
physicians plus there is also we had a
inspection a short while ago and the
inspector recommended a couple of
changes to our policy so if that has to
come through their profile members so
it's looking like that might be
available around October time and then
again will be just a committee before so
I would suggest a better program that in
October yeah you know treasury
management there are three reports one
in July one in November time on one in
January last year there was a special
task and finished group agreed that
meant for the three times to consider
the reports and then make
recommendations to Council no another
training session most members said they
thought that work well it seemed to work
well for an officer point of view and if
members were so decided to do that then
that could happen again this time about
you would need to get some volunteers
for the task and finish but I think I
also trying yet volunteered to that
young to be available
so then it's just that last time there's
four members so you probably need
another three members for that moment
into its Treasury magical tangle
the one of our volunteers or something I
would doesn't it I was completely out I
feel for you and on each other a lot of
spending but another Leah will thou
justic me down please did you get good
bit of background or treasure in my
management Paul yep it's basically the
treasury management function is where we
invest balances of the council over time
uses notice accounts etc and coal
accounts and it's the procedure and the
policy that's agreed I you there's a set
down laid down procedure policy which
banks we can actually invest with and
for how long and how much basement it
comes about you remember the Iceland
bank scalable yes he's trying to avoid
things like that because there's set lay
down criteria the banks have credit
score for this restaurant yeah and it's
all there and you're nodding to me so
our own bondage / but coming out yep
good working with you you're sorry how
are you doing working with your textures
11 why now there's only love to you i
think is probably types of fresh blood
well I think you've got some continuity
from cancer dry so it can also sort
retrospective question glacier which
they don't Riddler I didn't obviously
I'll just let me talk and is it possible
to say
the recommendations a report from home
office about the recommendations they've
given to district about the changes here
River you did positives or send out for
the members what happened a couple of
months ago there were here yeah it did
come in dude there's not no document
that oh no no its head that same one
that we haven't been able to get real or
so I played under the impression you
were saying because the reorganization
that's also had a knock-on effect okay
I'm actually meeting with Nick con to
discuss it surely even try and saw him
on the Treasury over the others victims
evening yet it yeah even the obviously
after the rock as well first of all I
can um just mean before 10 to July
although you could you reduce for the
new members which be able to send this
Republic document and new members yeah
yeah product you say they're generally
of it over so moving forward yeah quite
an interesting looking lips very much
line slope agency and changes to the
primary care trusts as a no they are
CCGs and took the change to public
health as well let's move deposit
accounts Council I think now this year's
eves opportune moments where as you look
at the Health Service generally
specifically the concerns of changes to
the county as well but this change is
getting about there in terms of your
the health economy in this county south
Moscow is not only great States at the
moment as a number falls getting shot
down at the moment although geriatrics
being one of them some serious
implications there for some of our
residents are very much like to be on
the agenda view and decline tend to
agree with that now in the whole health
and social care architect is changing is
movable saying England of work because
no cash and we have I the only
population in hospital certainly what
should we have another pastor distant
what not be human and but I think the
approach we owe it to our residents to
Uncle closer look and see if the things
actually gotta work and uses any cash
bail ideas or weighing word so that
young man words wonderful but it could
learn putting their money when I'm out
this anger work yeah so Thunder strange
what I don't know is how we prioritize
this link still be at one we have one
other one Jerry from the planning
meeting which was Miss rings phone what
what Wallin has been the impact where we
go how do we stand now and what's the
road ahead yes would machines farm
pyramid clean folks important here
because you want to go to the shepherd I
have kind of hands on the top I was the
total i think i think a few things going
to die the way by what I mention
abeyance some of these issues it's happy
enough with that bean paste that
the machines I think I can be combined I
mean things that came to life Jerry
wasn't a planning meeting but some
issues that came to light regarding a
number of these planning enforcement
issues was who's actually in planning
enforcement and who's doing what down
and till we actually established that
where we're going with that it'd be kind
of difficulty trying to work out how
we'll get all swishes I can forward you
the bar in panic enforcement's if you
want got an email confirming booze and
planning enforcement giver you but um I
think things were pretty down to be
assistant director planning you still
being paged the team needed planning
enforcement i believe is still open no
been filtered as yet by understanding
the rugged of eternity for this alone I
also question the other day you know
it's told I don't know don't know no
because I'm expecting politic on but
anything falls when they said they're
looking eternity for qualified internal
be able to for they told but you've
already got planned enforcement i think
is three or will be three members of
staff canteen enforcement would be for
mems and tart staff including the team
sorry three including the team leader
tech needs obviously being self
replacement there are two planners which
you turned neck depth and Yvonne done
yeah very enforcement so here internally
if they replace or they find a team
leader you've then got a spare planning
spot they're gonna have to feel so
whatever there will be a vacancy yeah
it's it might be you One wait on some of
the planning ones who's got building
control you like the planning protocols
and planning conditions and scheme of
delegation until such time as that's all
been finalized and deal with it so
September time I asked question I've
always had an issue or more so recently
done planning advice and I don't really
want to get to it now but basically is
what they say to the client and how that
affects ultimately the decision I wanted
two short weeks on I'm not agree on that
but one or two examples and I'll get
does that fall in what you're discussing
here or with that comment than you plan
on innovations and a cherry variant in
our decisions I also seemed to me to be
regularly if I'm wrong opportunities to
brigade some of these together for
planning issues and then there's my
assumes of the council's housing
strategy and homelessness of a lady d a
very close working so we could forget
some of these together and then the Z
ones that seem to stand out on their own
like the budget complaints and working
with other authorities which is an issue
we've already touched on this evening
I'm looking for advice do we need to set
up the project groups tonight or you
know you can wait and decide I mean the
budget process and consultation if you
go down and project
root root on that one you might not make
this year's budget process just pointing
out the neck the away first why day is
scheduled for the third of October and I
can see it's going to be a difficult
thing to actually get enough meetings
and a rapport which would probably come
in September time and get it all through
to effect this year's budget process
there is training on the budget on the
twenty-fourth of June and if members
have got concerns that might be the time
to point out while they're still trying
to sort out of the process rather than
the white get caught on later on because
it if the committeemen doesn't come up
with a
a recommendation soon enough it won't
affect this year's budget process I'm
just pointing that part al gym I love
you cause while I'm in the chair yes
it's just that in relation to
homelessness and council's housing
strategy we're actually doing review of
Housing Services and meet with the team
tomorrow I don't know at the moment I'm
not sure whether it's PNC all but anyway
that's the situation and so until I meet
with them tomorrow this is an outside
people involved I'm not sure the scope
of that so you may want to take that
into consideration but I also had a
question about what ever happened to the
review of housing for older people that
we started back in two thousand twelve
or thirteen and was never completed
because the county older people's
strategy was put on hold i believe
yeah I think it just it could they
couldn't find a demand within the
district itself you never actually prove
that there was a and need by the numbers
we didn't finish the review now it just
SAT there and I think in the end they
were just agreed to just show bit at
that point but it could I was just
obviously committee now I don't think
it's anyone here now but from Malcolm is
not part of the committee that was in
vulgar but I don't know people like able
to do was actually ratings and other
subjects over now right time I'll bet
you up to but i'm going to manage after
what i think that i didn't know put it
on the table for me it was just young
people and in particular school leavers
or actually just before school believers
and just are the council doing enough
working with our district schools to
keep those between ages 16 and 18 within
the district because I think there's a
lack of facilities for youngsters about
I teach we're in current I think by
default our schools aren't providing
enough for them and there aren't enough
facilities so they leave in the district
to go off and then that was making
anything come over to talk about housing
that actually a lot about the youngsters
and having to go out the district for
their education and not coming back but
also far the council didn't to encourage
kind of apprenticeship schemes in Owen
County responsibility yeah I think we're
quite a great people to actively great
appreciation fingertip it doesn't matter
create them or how are we promoting them
as a district council are we floated
into the business is a whole dinner so
she's not counting counting bath
braintree actually did a study only a
couple years ago Angada board and tryna
think what the acting in afternoons is
for young people not in is going than
for education me did a study on him for
the brides-to-be area I think you're a
lot of the guarantee so they don't
really tell it was just almost and a
short treaty that the district councils
is aware of the situation that is
happening all around the country are we
really doing enough are we satisfied
there's a council we know we're doing
lots of kind of encourage that we didn't
I meet Alicia is just a summary again
okay can I expand on your point I
a lot to point you raised but what we
could do is take this a bit further and
look at yet the age groups from the
primary school till high school and
ensure that they're on the right side of
the law we actually work with the place
and also in creative of the actors are
none that I able to go into higher
education then we can actually create
partnerships but does start at a younger
age and try to influence and to keep on
this right yeah I think I was talked in
the older one because obviously now is
compulsory that children stay in
education between 16 18 but as a
district we're quite limited in schools
with places and therefore the option is
to go to colleges or specific colleges
poor get involved in the friendship
scheme so a lot of variances in the
district are leaving the district going
to schools the habit of six full places
colleges in Southend thousand London
their legal industry and I think once
they've left it's sometimes you know
they establish themselves in other
places with regards the apprenticeships
I just think the district council maybe
have some influence still on trying to
promote a healthy my apprenticeship
clerical listening this first year they
make you um I'm interested here June's
to your Vic's but of time fitting but
we're splitting ourselves too thin
already and we've had help those desert
and it with the big issue and I think it
is a really big issue of insulin to the
council doesn't spend much time in the
past and I would like to see that
happened I can understand James point
although somebody who interceding I
didn't leave for this street operator
are very nearly did
I'm still here not a ball and chain quit
but I just wondering we can spell is
it's a lot worse than what we would
achieve a beastly engines beyond what's
the end point I think for me what the
environment was important on what you're
saying Bobby in quite online health
missions farm which is more internal
issue I think you something we meet ya
if residents with us say to us one thing
that we need to do from the last year's
look level what went wrong last year the
Michelin star was a thing that went
wrong in a big way yeah and I think we
need to scrutinize down and I wouldn't
diss grown fat [ __ ] harm if I'm
honest that I was gonna allow this isn't
gonna be popular I wouldn't actually be
looking at some things things are all
done in the planning for me there's a
lot on there we all have extensive
planning training plan is an ongoing
thing and I'm not quite sure needs to be
scrutinized in such detail for me I
would be lookin to think if you are 16
17 18 and Liberty their district and
colleagues design schools for you as a
college places for you in this district
and they approach the council how the
council deal with that would we have a
policy in place that said well actually
we've got certain companies we work with
to promote their apprenticeship schemes
you know we could possibly try and marry
the two together you know are we
confident in ourselves if the youngster
came to us and wanted to say man in the
district's I've been higher education on
friendship how would the council did
with that and how we got anything in
close already ok so you for that Kyle
just one right I don't know so now
potential southern I'm really sorry are
you can call me George
thank you what the bit I just just like
what about the business summons is a bit
that we hold the business that someone's
we know the businesses in the area and
do we need to enhance enhance out a bit
more to encourage apprenticeships within
those business I think the subject of
friendships is a kind of natural subject
to bring up with local businesses we do
have quite a good relationship with
businesses there's been lots of schemes
and incentives over the years that the
council has been involved with the shop
of my local thing so we do have a
relationship with them and that's not
something you could just keep bringing
up your fresh in just for the sake of it
perhaps if we look at a review and maybe
create a policy so don't know if we have
one right by something that would just
get things going in mind so I just let
go as the torrid answer to that today
two points funnies I think we I
understand the point nothing is very
valid however we are compression on
counter ground we don't have to get
County take yuval we we do have
Castle umbra hood will be sitting on the
new strategy group anyway which means
English historically into that and the
source partially which link directly
into that there are also county councils
around which so feedings they're not and
there are some cattle gases on scripting
and it's at County I think perhaps
George is written about the earlier age
group is very badly because County so no
73 thirteen-year-old certainly full inna
empty area there's nothing to take care
of and that could be very very important
and I think he then comes back to
Council bad Quinn we are it's a massive
subject health is a massive subject and
I think from my experience of last year
it looks fierce very fitting deigned and
we wouldn't actually come up match that
would then follow through frog it we
might come to announce a very but I
think there's ready tool that would be
done people would be done any way
through the uterus regroup in other
areas on you and it's possible pretty
member here to defend our castle only
all characters into the new stress
when we try to do something with health
before we have to get permission from
County anyway because it's county that
has the power to scrutinize yes yeah
they still have that they let us lost
what we could do a similar to win the
health and well-being winner first
starting I think you still chair their
own time where they came in spoke about
it people questioned them I've already
spoken to our communications and then
knowing who deals with the health people
and we could put something together to
get the various the clinical
commissioning group the health and
well-being board etc they come to a
meeting and companion of members
actually want them to cover if you can
tell me in vance then i can make sure
that their presentations and reports
cover those those sub areas i'm not sure
i could get it for the July meeting I've
got nothing on the agenda for the July
meeting at the perfectly falken can i
sort of i think you know a lot of this
stuff what we talked about these the
background work done okay let's throw
the ball at the show you what can you
rec which one would you give us some
guidance on the you would put a package
together you could actually do something
in july you could we attack between farm
was a big kind of work so we need or
that's a bit of a can of worms i think i
probably need to sit down the chairman
and vice-chairman of work
where you want to go okay well who you
want what I would possibly say is the
complaints process of the council you
can probably not that my life by just
having a report on that for the July
meeting okay I mean that would that work
when we don't want to show me because
I've statistics on that land yeah
there's a written copy this report this
sadistic from today would probably but
then that would buy at the time yeah
it's probably an item that could be done
in a single night by the committee and
could we do also do a Community Safety
Partnership one of those that night um
yeah probably could ask them to prepare
a report we'd have to ask the portfolio
holder in charge of the serious pain
whether they could attend that date the
seventh of July
23 weeks you're not giving enough time I
give it two straight weeks in every week
and we're struggling to come up with in
something to feel the means you don't
just wait to come up ever half an hour I
appreciate appreciate could we tailor
one of the community safety meetings to
focus on young people because I have
been party to safety working in terms of
sort of project so 26 punishment of lime
can we focus on that we didn't yeah um
basically what we've done in the past
has got them to detail some of the
projects now there's no reason when
you've heard their report is just to ask
them to come back with details about a
specific project that you've got
interested going to be ludicrous your
cruise crucial crucial through is
hitting the gas yeah I do Alex do you
want to come in while matter and yes
following up Council Burton's point
quite a few the local schools don't have
a civil war do you think that the
required and risk me or the the process
of putting them together and
constructing them I think some of the
local colleges in yourself and
embezzlement now strapping to to fill
their places now that there's so many 64
the white is unfortunately regarding
apprenticeships we're in the black area
for employment from itself into dreadful
area for employment prisoner government
and others in the government in a pledge
to increase apprenticeships yes and I
think Scott's acceptance on the young
working group for the various businesses
and where is he encouraged to increase
apprenticeships and for companies to
take up apprenticeships it's been
already and looks I believe who's so
who's how many of our companies in the
district my old friend is not it's not
be more likely that mr. step through to
my step test it who's in charge okay why
could I just say that on that basis
perhaps what council person might be
looking at is if business development is
working as it should mr. council I don't
light a little close on the table that
our next meeting that we look at the
complaint scheme and the CSS ESP are
people happy with that yeah and then we
can have a chat at the end of the
meeting about where you want to go to
various footage groups that's okay and
if it is on the 7th this church will be
chairing because I'm in Norway
send us a regular 209 yeah cuz for to
come back for came to be tons Vince
nipple I mean that cheese baby if
possible have a question in there about
how includes you functionally now moving
the comedy saw the partnership with
which it was main search page from the
general populace in to the police
station they closed the search box and
how does that work because the
communications in the old I don't get
into munications and assess big dreams
did we ended and then 20 safety and they
disbanded it said pelicula completa
placed a bit maybe if you and people I
was going on across all odds on stage
playing over nothing right I'm better
just step in at this point
the CSK yes physically was the staff
were going to be located at police
station as far as I'm aware if that
happened it's only been in the last week
Walter to close it happens I don't think
they've even moved yet them deal about
six weeks with regards to the meeting
that she's used to have before the
strategic you have it all the Paris ago
that is now and by the rockford hundred
a stroke it was Brian Brown comes along
to the boxford hundred meeting and talk
to all the parishes they're basically
they weren't turning up to the meetings
separately so it's decided i think that
the CSP presence would go to them so
this is what other ? regice ago
religiously and we were just sold that
was all would be disbanded and we would
be content about nothing and i represent
represent apparel that I was aware it
was approved by the meeting now we were
told for this no it wasn't the tablets
you know hey we were actually advised
and like it wasn't in the last CSP
meeting which we had which Joad chaired
she brought up some stats with regards
to representation and the district level
was it no it was let us at the parish
level with hear what the Augustus I must
have linked the end now as I say they go
to the boxer
meetings and the representatives of the
parishes should be feeding back to the
other parish meant was it nothing what
happens my suggestion will be if you if
you're from a periscope you spoke to
your quad force engagement I'm slinging
lunching because i just cannot be
registered okay who are you obey upon
this empty life like okay symptom July
everybody with this gentleman in the
chair while i'm setting up a field
something methodology i think will yeah
we burn she has don't know yet and now
the key decisions doctor anything
anybody thinks i should call in or three
we were i am calling you can't call in a
bunch of money no all right okay thank
you for that mr. okay God whites
yesterday I'm gonna find a nicer the key
decision document as i said at the
training ease so you get free decision
scrutiny some
called Coleman but if you want further
information then you can ask for it if
you know there's an item on their prior
to the meeting that you're interested in
a maund additional information then you
can either contact the lead officer or
let me know and i'll see if i can get
the lead officers shown up to the
meeting to discuss it now lovely go go
go kingshill dr your engineers one very
important things ok the first one number
or 15 the empty house strategy I've
already seen the report on that one and
the decision is June we published on the
twelfth of june so you're already got
the report in the member arena ok yeah
number 5 15 the Hound strategy that was
on the KDC document the last time and
according to the minutes the strategy
provides an update to the council's 2014
housing strategy the stretch twill seeks
to influence and key partners and
promote the provision of quality
affordable housing in the district and
promote the creation of sustainable
communities for residents I mean that
one as far as i know is still being
prepared no I will say that either side
and I'm Sid draft of its own yeah that
one is giving out
they're at some stage now number 6 15
the advice servicing services
commissioning is due to be discussed in
tective tomorrow night is PNC report but
all members should have seen a copy of
that at the current time okay and then
finally the only actual new one on the
key decision document 7 15 additional
fees and charges planning policy
documents it's actually to make up for
these documents that have finally been
approved it covers the allocations clan
that was adopted on the twenty-fifth of
february2014 the hotly area action plan
which was adopted twenty-fifth of
februari 14 the development management
plan which was adopted on this 16 to
December 2014 the london Southend
Airport and environments joint area
action plan which was adopted on the
sixteenth of december 2014 and finding
the roster of town center area action
plan and that's adopted on the twenty
first of april 2015 basically it's to
outline the fees if people want printed
copy and if i tell you the most
expensive document will cost 14 pounds
but it's because it covers more than two
boys two doors and more
that comes and finds our bases finish
sleepily thoughts comments on any level
Marlene I the nice to the neutral
palette holder is here I focus on the
box had me feel threatened me and very
much gratitude I have signed you up but
I haven't seen them powerless strategy
any other points with Rosalie thank you
all for coming I think we've all stupid
stuff out the available to work had
German we need to be able to work
together to easily and i wish you all a
safe journey home see all the exit now
legend